rentrée scolaire commence
progressivement en espagne et c'est une
rentrée des classes qui se rassure
indique le gouvernement espagnol
alors les dates de rentrée varie dans
chaque région et c'est à chaque
communauté autonome de mettre en place
ses propres restrictions alors
globalement le port du masque est
obligatoire à partir de l'âge de 6 ou 12
ans le nombre d'élèves par classe est
limité un lavage des mains régulier est
assurée et la distance sociale également
alors chaque établissement un centre de
santé de référence pour être
accompagnées dans le protocole en cas de
personnes positives dans les abysses
mans si une personne est positive toute
la classe devrait être en quarantaine
alors pour veiller au respect tout ces
mesures de sécurité les inspections
techniques vont être réalisés dans
chaque établissement alors à madrid des
milliers de professeurs et directeurs
doivent se soumettre à des tests
sérologiques provoquant de longues files
d'attentes dans la capitale en catalogne
ce sont 500 mille tests qui sont prévues
jusqu'en novembre
l'inquiétude continue d'être réel pour
les professeurs qui se demandent quel
sera le protocole en cas de
contamination dans l'établissement mais
aussi sur comment vont s'organiser les
cours dans les établissements de petite
taille et pour les étudiants toutes ces
conditions de rentrée ne sont pas
suffisantes il convoque donc une grève
les 16 17 et 18 septembre prochain pour
protester